Karen avid author of sin and second city
I'm from Philadelphia originally i was
born in philadelphia and grew up in a
town called right outside of
Philadelphia called norristown which is
a sort of blue collar blue collar edging
towards rough town probably the most
famous person who's from there is Tommy
Lasorda and it gives you any indication
about my high school I went to Catholic
school for 16 years which of course you
know i'm sure the nuns would be very
proud i I'm here writing about
prostitutes and my next book is about
strippers so I'm sure that they would
find something to say about that but the
timeless orders from my town and he used
to come back frequently about once a
year because he had I he had nieces and
nephews in the school and would give us
pep talks about how we too can escape
this town and we're not stuck there and
and he would try to sort of bring this
message of entrepreneurship and you know
lift yourself up by your bootstraps kind
of thing and it was a it was an odd town
because it was if there were any wealthy
pockets it was blue-collar wealthy a
couple of my friends who had money their
families and construction companies and
carpet Lang companies and and most of
their fathers were high school dropouts
who's to you nose began these companies
and a lot of like random mafioso ties it
was it was kind of a colorful place to
grow up
you